foreign
[Music]
listeners friends
that might be a little bit of a stretch
listeners
welcome to an intimate and perhaps
boring we're gonna try to make it as
unboring as possible but we are doing a
close reading of a text by Louis
altuzair and Louis altuzar
in my opinion is the best Marxist on
Marxism
I will stand by that this is that's a
stake of a claim
you don't think okay
it's partially personal just because he
applies this structuralist method and
I'm quite familiar with the
structuralist method it's kind of where
I do a lot of the rest of my stuff so
the way that he I wouldn't say combines
because that would be incorrect but the
way that he uses the terms it feels very
comfortable to me so it feels very homey
and a lot of the problems that I would
say are stereotypical of Marxism or even
the ones that we use as as Straw Men
I think he solves a lot of those
problems for me theoretically but this
is very much a theoretical text it's
very much a commentary on other Marxist
theory
so if you're looking for uh just
straight up Praxis or how to organize a
a Soviet or organize a union this
altuser is probably not the guy to go to
but he was a party man
he was a party man until the end yeah
yeah well he's he's one of those uh
French thinkers that has a kind of a
sketchy uh some sketchy events in his
life and a bit of a weird ending to it
all but um maybe maybe that's a tired
out subject that shouldn't be gone into
right now I'd rather look at what he's
thinking about and I'd like I'd like to
go into it I don't know what happened
didn't he kill his wife yeah yeah that
that's it yeah that's I mean that's the
thing and pleaded insanity or something
like that wasn't it like a psychotic
break yeah yeah I think he he did it got
away with it I I mean I I don't know
yeah I think it happened but it's so
often presented as like this is what's
wrong with Marxism that it's just so
easy to just gloss over it's like oh the
loose jumped out his window this is
what's wrong with post-modernism like
all that I don't I don't know
but like I said this is like 19th
century biographical readings of
people's work that's not that's not
Kosher on this podcast anyway this was
this was 25 years before that and I
don't I don't know that Marxism is the
kind of thing that causes uh wife
killings on mass maybe it is yeah
yeah but I wanted to start because this
is oh it's so dense I don't even know
how we're gonna do this in an episode
it's a nice intimate episode Eric and we
can we can bring back some of our other
intimate episodes uh I found a lot of
crossover here with systems theory which
we talked about I guess this is like
almost two years ago that we did a deep
dive into systems theory yeah we did and
I found some crossover here which is
another reason I probably like all
tuzera among Marxist but I wanted to
start generally
now reading quotes but what problems is
he addressing because he's talking
it sounds like at least he's really
talking to marxists about what's wrong
with Marxism and our last episode was on
post Marxism with Diego and we're kind
of gonna head in the direction of
looking at what the possibilities of
post-marxist
Theory might look like
the first version of that the people who
kind of coined the term laclau and moof
uh they did this in the 80s and they
gave us their prescriptions for what
post-marxism looked like it didn't
really jive with any of us
we didn't really I don't know it didn't
it didn't didn't give that hit didn't
give that sense of satisfaction but if
we are going to do post-marxism I'd like
to
start with the best instead of starting
with a straw man
yeah well this was like I mean the
moments this is the 60s we're looking at
right we're looking at four marks from
the mid 60s so this was a time of of
huge you know like a rich creative
period of of development and expansion
of of you know Alpha Sarah was like the
the chair of uh like a a major French
Marxist organization
and he was running a reading group
and eventually produced the book reading
marks with Etienne balabar and Jack
Rancier and and all these other really
famous thinkers and I was just watching
a video with balabar in it like he's
he's still gone a few of them are still
going I think we even did an episode
where we was that with our Rancier and
um our uh our later Frankfurt School Guy
what's his name yeah we did rossier the
hatred of democracy I believe yeah and
um so these guys are still around in the
60s but then in the 70s you know
apparently Marxist theorization started
to poop out and it needed to be
reinvigorated and this is where sort of
post Marxist kind of thinking comes in
is like you know 1985 hegemony and
socialist strategy we gotta we gotta get
rid of this sort of old catches that all
the Marxist theorization is in like base
superstructure we got to get rid of that
like that's kind of there
angle on it but in a way I do I do think
that this reading marks group and
there's four marks and some of althea's
ideas are almost like the uh what the
the the the the precursor to post
Marxism they seemed it seems to have
started to open up Marxism in a way that
gave
post-modernism
later the chance to kind of
have its way with Marx's Theory yeah we
needed to neo-liberalize it not saying
that the postmodern is neoliberalized it
but the LA clown move version is like we
need to focus on individual struggles
and bring everybody together and Marxism
is one option on the supermarket of
options and capitalism is the thing that
maintains all these choices so we don't
need to do anything to it and that kind
of knee-jerk aversion to totalization
was a major thing as well they don't
they don't want to totalize we can't we
can't subsume all of historical
development under a single theoretical
framework kind of thing
and that's what they saw you know I
think they saw althazarian Marxism as
both renewing you know the study of Marx
along with the influx of gram Chi and
and and and
Benjamin and the rise of the new left
but also
um kind of taking it to its limits and
showing us that it's it can't move
forward on the old Concepts anymore that
Marxism has been stuck with which
whatever the Marxism world view Marxism
kind of thing how it's how it's
developed over the 20th century after
Marx where Marx already had said in his
lifetime I'm not a Marxist but
oops there's a difference there between
you know Marxism and marxian Theory
where you're where you're studying marks
sometimes it's marxology which is which
is alive and well today by the way and
it's and it's very very interesting and
alphazer is an important figure in that
too for some people yeah this brings up
another huge issue that I found because
we I mean in shorthand in conversation
as a podcast as a YouTuber I you gotta
say just sometimes this is what Marxism
believes or this is the Marxist world
view and especially reading this you get
the sense of like he's he's boxing with
a lot of other ideas there's no such
thing as Marxism there's not even such
thing as Orthodox Marxism there's so
many schools each is dealing with a
different part for example we've spent
we spent like all of January and
February talking about the situationist
international and gideborough Society of
spectacle didibor specifically says
I like early marks I don't like late
marks late marks is to academic he's
having debates he's getting into all
these details he feels like he has to
defend his theory I like early marks now
this is the flip side of that because
all too there says you shouldn't read
early marks you shouldn't read angles
the only thing that matters is late
marks which is uh the marks of capital
and yeah that's right and he and he says
he marks later marks fixed early marks
but we shouldn't be paying attention to
early marks so what are the problems
here what is he trying to fix
first of all humanism that's right
humanism is bringing into Marxism all of
these I Bourgeois ideals you could call
them the Bourgeois ideals of the
Enlightenment
you're we're not talking about equality
we're not talking about Freedom we're
not talking about Consciousness all of
that stuff about how capitalism feels
which is especially what the board was
focused on he's like capitalism feels
isolating it feels atomizing and the
fact that it feels bad I mean this is a
sorry this is a little bit of a
simplification but you know we need to
be focusing on these human values that
are contradistinguished with what
capitalism is doing none of that
really matters to altuzer yeah like
apparently he he introduced the idea
that there's a break in Marx an
epistemological break between the early
and the late marks that's one of the
sort of enduring controversies of his
work did Marx completely jettison his
early humanism all his talk of
alienation and the development of human
capacities to their fullest potential
and you know kind of a manifestation of
a true manifestation of human nature
as opposed to this sort of one-sidedness
this this fragmentation this
subordination to Capital
that's the question did he carry that
over into his later work or did he go
through this epistemological break such
that we can like periodize Marx even
into four phases but with a clear break
between the early stuff and the later
stuff that's alphazer argues for the
break and he wants to have like kind of
almost like a developmental theory of
Marx where he
gets rid of older Concepts and brings in
new ones and that rubs a lot of people
the wrong way especially ones that like
Capital but they don't want to see it as
like not using this like they still
think alienation is an important concept
where we're alienated from our sort of
true
well the path to to developing
capacities or or human nature yeah one
of the things he says for example is one
Phantom is more especially crucial than
any other today the shade of Hegel to
drive this Phantom back
into oh sorry to drive this Phantom back
into the night we need a little more
light on Marx or what is the same thing
a little more Marxist light on Hegel
himself we can then escape from the
ambiguities and confusions of the
inversion
so how do we do this quickly
um
basically he says if you just say that
Marx inverted Hegel then you're still
doing Hegel right if you've got a
dialectic and then you just say no this
one's in top on top instead of the other
one then you're doing the same thing and
altazir is very
uh impassioned about the fact that Marx
is not an inversion of Hegel and Mark
said that he was but Marx was raw right
or at least early Marx was wrong so we
need to at least look carefully at what
production has changed and we are not
going to be thinking about this binary
anymore between superstructure and bass
that in his mind has caused so many of
the problems of marxist not agreeing
with each other and yeah he's going to
bring structuralism as an antidote to
this representationalism especially when
it comes to history history is really
important here history is infinitely
complex as any of us knows but if you
come at it too conceptually or too
representationalist Lee then you're just
going to be finding the thing that
you're looking for imposing it on
history and you actually don't get any
explanations out of that and it's not
gonna figure out you know how is art or
literature or Theory
how does it fit in to the
capitalist economy I guess you could say
that
that every one of these different modes
of Life which he gets from a
structuralist by the name of cloud Libby
Strauss you have to look at production
individually you have to look at
production in every case because
whatever
I want to say discourse is the first
word that comes to mind you probably
wouldn't like that but you know all of
these different codified systems that we
have that are developing we got art
and the other aspects of culture theory
is a developmental process builds upon
itself family structures you can't go
back and ultimately say
that the capitalist economy determines
each of these things you have to look at
their own modes of production
yeah it's a it's a little difficult to
understand what he does on the
production side from
just this one article
or the the this book by the way four
marks 1965 is like a collection of
articles that he published
this was like him bursting onto the
scene in the 60s too right he's he
didn't publish a whole lot in the 50s
and then suddenly in the 60s he
publishes four marks and reading marks
or reading capital
and he becomes a huge intellectual
figure and gets embroiled in in also
these enormous controversies with like
European marxists from like Britain and
other places
um particularly I just wanted to read
that quote that particularly another
famous Marxist named EP Thompson who uh
who says he he I refuse these spurious
choices which theoretical practice seek
to oppose and instead I declare
unrelenting intellectual war against
such marxisms I do so from the tradition
of one whose major Founders is Marx
um he really really did not like what
they were doing well to Marx uh okay
fair enough there's some other figures
who who didn't like them either but
that's probably the spiciest quote
declaring unrelenting intellectual War
so there's there's maybe the origin of
infighting on the left hippy Thompson
and no no that can't be the origin but
can you tell me like what was his what
was his specific objection because I
haven't read that bit
well he's EP Thompson wrote the um the
uh what's the name of the text the the
formation of the working class in in in
England and I think it is the
structuralist methodology in this
anti-humanism
or this application of structuralism
anti-humanism like where's the agency
right this was a big time of talking
about the difference between structure
and agency and and officers thinking
seems to come down pretty clearly on the
side of structure and really you know
diminishes agency quite a bit and I
think that rubs some the wrong way
depending on your view of of like how
and where Revolution is supposed to come
from
uh if there's no agency in the picture
then then that just seems like a
vanishingly difficult goal to achieve if
you have to wait for the right
um
we call it conjunction to to provide the
conditions for a revolution to become
possible and then the generation of a
revolutionary subjectivity and the
fusion of all these subjectivities into
a single Mass which can oppose the
ruling classes
so that becomes vanishingly unlikely if
you're a structuralist who sees
the structural causation as the dominant
Force shaping shaping human reality and
if I can give a defense of altuzir on
this point
the criticism is that
if you if you try to read marks too
philosophically this is something the
board would have said to if you make it
into an intellectual preoccupation
then you're not facing any of the actual
challenges of Labor in real situations
or Praxis
and all that stuff
I would say
I would say okay it's possible however
the defense of what altuser is doing is
saying it like again with structuralism
specifically
and we could go back to as the origin of
structuralist linguistics with like so
sir or something that
none of these boundaries are closed
if you want to close a boundary you want
to say okay the economy is a closed
boundary or you want to say the
proletariat is a closed boundary or even
the commodity I guess you could
I I want to I want to specify that a
little bit more I don't have the uh the
time to do that right now but when you
look for all these Marxist terms and
then you say this is that
altuzer is a structuralist it is saying
you are signifying something you're
representing it to your mind in a way
that makes you miss all the details and
for him especially you're missing all
the details of
how something comes into the world
so especially I mean most people know
altuzer for his critique of ideological
state apparatuses
his research into ideological state
apparatuses or theories about it come
from the most specific examples and draw
or try to develop conclusions from there
because if you think that ideology is
just a lie that everyone believes then
the easy salute there should be an easy
solution you just convince them hey this
is a lie that you believe whereas with
the ideological State apparatus it's
this mess that you're called into
unfreely you don't make a choice to be
deceived by ideology you are birthed
into ideology which is why you can't
just trust subjective subjectivist
accounts of everyone's believing
ideology no as soon as you answer your
name you are part of the apparatus of
ideology so while it might be true that
you know if you're trying to form a
union
then then altuzar might not be all that
useful because all you need to say is
the bosses are exploiting your labor you
have the capacity to change it let's go
that might be true but if you're a
Marxist theorist and he's really talking
to theorists he's a he's a centralized
Parisian academic
if you really want to figure out where
these points of tension are you need to
be less representationalist you have to
signify a little less or at least
understand that the things you're
looking for in history the things you're
looking for in development the things
you're looking for in society are not
going to be as simple as putting a
Mark's word on a problem that you notice
like just because you feel lonely you
can't just rush in there and put
alienation right on top of it you have
to look at the production you have to
look at the production of what material
events you could say LED you to having
this feeling or living this life
so I would I would push against saying
this is not useful for Marxism because
it is really a call like most of the
structuralists to say the thing that you
say you're talking about is not actually
what you're talking about
I get the sense that these slogan
earring even just
similar seems like similar to what
you're saying there's a lot of slogans
that seem to be going around
even that that chapter on Linguistics in
in in the Thousand plateaus I can't
remember the French term they used but
they're basically talking about slogans
and and kind of like watch words thing
repeated phrases yeah you're you're at
your dumbest when you let words think in
your place which is something that we
all do a lot I do that a lot I I just
get the sense that this was a big thing
and to be fair to the alphas air he's
working on the one side
against like sort of the more hardcore
stalinists and on the other side he's
working against what we already
mentioned like the humanist marxists who
are influenced by Lou Koch and sarte and
they're delving into early marks Marxist
humanism and their hegelian their
hegelianizing marks and so he's working
against both of those directions he's
working against the more sort of
stalinist which was which was kind of
unraveling around that time with all the
atrocities come into light and
and even within his own party right the
French Marxist party he's he's a member
but he's critical of them and he's
critical of both currents humanism and
stalinism in in Marx's Theory so he's
working against he's he's hemmed in on
both sides by by different things he's
he's got in mind what he's working
against but yeah he has some nice
phrases about that like we shouldn't let
these sort of slogans do our thinking
for us
but there are a lot of Officer sap bites
I think what comes out of this text for
Marx is he calls himself he's a Marxist
in philosophy
so he's doing theorizing and he's doing
philosophy and he makes that clear and
there's also people taking umbrage with
that as if as if getting the theory
right is gonna do the class struggle for
us
um
I don't know if that's really a fair
critique but you know that's that's the
sort of that's the sort of uh invective
people throw around so that's how it
goes and
whether or not Alpha Sarah is still an
important figure in many people's
thinking especially for bringing Lacon
into play in Marxist theory but also
structuralism so
he's a good guy to read anyway this was
a this was a fascinating chapter to read
and he says that Marx gives I guess from
a
a structuralist standpoint he gives the
terms but the terms are never just the
terms you have to look at before you can
draw a conclusion about an individual
situation
you have to actually look at the
material factors going into that so he
he likes when Marx writes uh the 18th
Premiere the Civil War in France so he's
kind of
as a theorist like self-admittedly I'm
doing Theory but he's also saying theory
is not about drawing a giant
cartoon picture of the history of the
world theory is about looking at
specific details and finding out the
methods of production that come into
there and he says basically no one has
done this
um except for gramshi everyone else is
on the list sart especially is on
the SAT sorry is it on this list
but he said ground she is the only one
who followed up to the explorations of
Marx even Engels is on the list
yeah and and to be fair to his
philosophy position too if you look at
reading marks pretty early on there's a
chapter on how to read he talks about
like a method of reading and that's this
famous symptomatic method of reading
where you're not looking at what the
text means you're trying to look at the
conditions which allowed this reading of
a text to be produced
so you're reading in a very presentist
mode and you're trying to look at what
is this how is this relevant how can we
bring this into the now but at the same
time paying attention to both the
conditions that produced this text and
then the conditions under which we are
producing our new text and that's the
kind of the nutshell of the symptomatic
reading method which he develops and
applies to Capital with this reading
group with balabar and Rancier and at Al
and uh it's it's fascinating and in here
you can see the same sort of thing going
on with you know Lenin's looking at for
instance he's looking at what's going on
in Russia but he's also been reading
right he's he's experience he's he's
building his revolutionary Theory not
just on the world around him but he's
looking at earlier texts like the 18th
Premiere you mentioned and and even you
know other revolutions the 1905 the
commune Germany 1840
what is it seven or eight failed
Revolution there and he's looking at all
of these and reading
is the way we do that we uncover this
knowledge and experience what Revolution
can do and what it can't do under what
conditions does it fail so for him this
is an important Venture so
come to it from theorized Marxism and
and and alter the theory and do these
little reading groups right with our
symptomatic reading strategy so I have a
question for you what's up so if we're
if we're gonna look at these because he
wants to do you know you you can't look
at Theory separate from the mode of
production that is the economy and he
says you know it's correct as Engels
said that if we theorize Society
it's going to be economic in the last
instance so we're not in economic
determinism
um I don't think Marx is an economic
determinist I don't think that a lot of
people do I think that shoddy readings
that pop up very often or tweets you
know they are economic determinants
they're saying like the the stuff you're
talking about doesn't matter it's the
mode of production but
productive activity for him is going to
be present as soon as you start doing
Theory so my question that I can't
really figure out from this because
when when we get to you know post 80s
Theory or post 80s like literature
analysis then we look at an author we
look at that where they were born we
look at their class position and say a
whole bunch of stuff like oh this is
reproducing Bourgeois ideology and it's
because this person was born in this
place at this time so if we're gonna
Read Literature Like That do you how do
you think that's what he's saying like
we need to be very concrete about where
all of our products are not necessarily
a product that is you know bought and
sold but even a novel
we need to look at the very details
under which that emerged and including
the author's personal biography
is he saying that because this this this
article came out before any of that was
a concern in in literature Theory I
think but
is that where he's is that where he's
going with this
I don't know that would be maybe
something you'd have to read the text to
answer or carefully you know I I
wouldn't get the sense that it's it's
the the conditions that produced it the
author or shape their life
I mean that would be a part of it but
you're you're looking at the conditions
that are going on behind your back as
well at the same time as you're reading
the text you're looking at your own
conditions you have to have a theory
again because you have to have a theory
of of sort of what's going on in the
world so you can and how to grasp it so
you can do this president's reading and
produce a text that that is
you know key to the issues so they're
not doing marxology they're not
interested in like getting marks right
so much as they are applying marks in
the right way and and and get getting
rid of what they don't need and and and
renovating or or adding what they do
need
so I think it's but you do have to look
at the the conditions under which the
text you're reading was produced and
then your own
so it's like you know what we say is is
now you have to have positionality you
have to you have to put yourself in your
research you have to make your your
commitments and your interests and your
status and position like known
so that someone who comes along later
and reads the texts can be like okay
well this person has these kinds of
commitments and these kinds of beliefs
so I can sort of use that to help me
read their own text I don't know
positionality of the researcher that's a
big thing we're always taught but I
think I don't know symptomatic reading
seems a little more
complex and and and uh
has a goal as opposed to just kind of
being honest about where you're uh where
your funding is coming from or something
like that yeah that's kind of a this
this fantasy of transparency like if you
put it all on the page then it's true or
then you've then you've addressed the
potential issues I I don't think that's
what he's saying really it's more like
history and if you want to divide
Society right you can divide Society
into a bunch of stuff you can say
politics we've got economy over here we
got the artistic production and
production of literature over here
and the concept if we can get into the
text and the title of the text this word
over determination
because over determination
there's a an infinite complexity
that I think he thinks most marxists
will not admit to there's just an
infinite complexity there's accidents
there's stuff that seemingly comes out
of nowhere unpredictable events and you
can't theorize this kind of kind of goes
back to our systems theory stuff before
you have a position of observation but
to theorize anything you have to reduce
complexity you have to take all of the
events that happen ever
and reduce them into a sort of narrative
now Marxism all marxisms do that all
theories You could argue do that
but he's arguing for you have to start
on a detail start on an instance don't
say that everyone's just stupid and
deceived by ideology you got to find out
the actual events in which ideology is
brought into the world
and kind of
mirroring the Khan
pun intended the mirror stage would be
one of those events if you could if you
could argue his at his moment of
interpolation is that you're already
caught in ideology the only thing you
could ever do is look back at the moment
you were in ideology because you can
never be outside and as a theorist you
can never be outside of theory and as a
historian you are never outside of
history and I think a lot of his
complaints or objections to
the way Marxism is being done by unnamed
people people that he accuses of this
and that is that
if you're if you're a true Marxist
you look at the means of production
which is the most not as a
representation but as the most
concrete event of what one person does
at One Moment In Time and then you work
out from there instead of saying we're
going to start with Concepts and then
find what those Concepts represent which
you know is kind of EX or not even kind
of it's exactly what structuralism on
the whole was really about
this term doesn't refer to This One
Singular closed off reality it belongs
to a chain of things that it's not it's
a differential thing so I don't know I'm
as you can probably tell I'm I'm I'm
standing this
pretty hard because I agree with it that
if you look for something especially in
a in a word as complex as history you're
gonna find whatever you want there
because it's infinitely complex the
question is if you're doing theory about
something Marxist theory in this case
you have to acknowledge the things that
you're simplifying and to his mind
humanist Marxism hegelian Marxism
representationalist Marxism that's just
sneaking in all of these aspects of
classical economics
um and then looking for them and then
finding them and then saying look I
found the thing that I'm looking for
that's not how you do proper Theory
yeah yeah and it's interesting in view
of the symptomatic reading that he's
his his concept explain that I'm not
sure what that means
the symptomatic reading well that's like
what I was saying before about reading
with the
reading with um you're not looking at
the meaning of the text per se on the
page you're trying to get to the
conditions of
the production of this text what
conditions lay behind the production of
this text and and you're doing that both
for the text you're reading and and that
time that it came out of and and your
own reading of the text we're reading
let's say we're reading Capital right
now we need a sense of our art the
conditions which may be influencing are
producing our own reading right if we're
reading it in a presentest way
and and his actually his his definition
of ideology is is about you know the
imaginary relationship of people to
their real conditions of existence and
the the imaginary is is like a technical
term from Lacon
um which we're probably not going to go
into that side of things but yeah
imaginary relationship to your real
conditions of existence so ideologies in
in altosphere's definition is going to
influence your reading and you have to
be aware of that
as far as you can be Can You Escape
ideology can we ever step out of it well
that's always been the big problem right
with arguing about false consciousness
and why people do things that seem to be
against their own interests because of
ideology because our false consciousness
something but that's
another kind of maybe humanist Marxist
idea that alphasair is pushing back
against right because the Simplicity of
the alpha Syrian or the the the humanist
marxists they simplify by using hegel's
dialectic which sounds crazy because
there's nothing simple about it but for
him right over determination
is a Confluence of of multiple
contradictions that create a certain
situation or a conjunction right and and
that's how history proceeds to these
conjunctions right because when Marx
starts Capital right he's he's like
we're gonna abstract right that's what
we have to do we have to start with
abstraction he has that nice quote about
you know you can't use a microscope to
find Value you can't you can't break
something down with experiments and find
some some physical substance of value
you have to the first thing you have to
do is abstract and so what's the basic
form of of
capitalist mode of production is the
commodity form so he starts with the
commodity form and then he gets to value
and then he gets to money in the third
in the in the next chapter
in those first few chapters of capital
so that's
you know the Marxist method
okay it's abstraction
but yeah this this what I was saying
this the simplification of
this dialectical perspective that he
thinks these humanist marxists are using
the dialectic is never over determined
because alphabong
is is suppression and overcoming it
internalizes the previous contradiction
and it and it kind of doesn't
play a role then in the next stage of
development
it suppresses the former contradiction
as it overcomes it suppression
conservation cancellation all those
meanings we're told that Alpha Haven has
has all these weird meanings and so you
get to a whole eventually the idea
but you've gotten there from a
determination one one stage is
determinative of of of the
contradictions and etc etc you don't get
over determination is the is the issue
right so that's why over determination
and then he gives this long example of
how Russia over time
collected all of these contradictions
right it was
very Progressive but it was also very
very backwards it had a czar base
essentially like a king but it was also
kind of modernizing at the same time and
had to extraordinarily Progressive
elements in a society it was the the odd
man out in the uh geopolitical landscape
it had the most and therefore it was the
uniquely the place where Revolution
would happen if it were to happen
anywhere and it did
1905 and then again
a decade later and it wasn't supposed to
happen there
but although there's very against that
kind of language like oh it's supposed
to occur in Germany first
and he says this supposed to
is a bad reading of cause and effect so
I don't know what kind of what what
mental definition like heuristic are you
using when you hear over determination
because what I'm working with is
you are saying that like one
contradiction
you can isolate it you can simplify it
enough so that it looks like a single
contradiction and honestly I don't know
if that if
current hegelians actually do this I
don't think they do but his objection at
least to hegelianism in general is you
find the contrary contradiction that
produced the next stage and you can
simplify it enough so that it looks like
it's just one
whereas over determination means that
there's there's contradictions that you
notice there's contradictions that you
don't notice there's nothing that you
could call a movement of History because
history is an infinite amount of events
and for it to be something that one
thing leads to the next you would have
to reduce all the events that are
important from all the events or
necessary would be his term the
necessity you would have to separate
those from all the events that are
unnecessary or that are accidental and
to do this as a theorist I think you
could say in his terms that's just
irresponsible that's giving a position
to human knowledge and theoretical
knowledge that just dominates you know
all of nature every single thing that
happens where you're like I can sit here
and determine this thing from this thing
from this thing
whereas his mode of looking into these
is let's take a single example let's
look for the contradictions in one
example and then if we have time you
know if we have enough time in our life
then we can move out from there
or do you have a different definition of
over determination sorry that was a long
roundabout way of asking what do you
think over determination means
yeah my
I mean my my heuristic is usually that
if if determination in this sense for
him I think
dialectic is is a simple
dialectic is simplistic okay you know
okay whatever as difficult as hegel's
texts are
as a motor of history that the dialectic
would be simple so you can't really just
take hegel's dialectic and invert it in
the sense of just giving it a new object
instead of spirit and in mind it's now
material reality you can't just do that
you'll have to transform the dialectic
to its core
right and and for him the outcome of
that is is instead of working with
simple contradictions between two
opposed
elements we're looking at an over
determination where multiple
contradictions accrue in a certain and
that's another be historical if you want
to look at examples of that sort of
thing and it's same sort of thing with
Marx right he's abstracting what I was
saying he's abstracting the commodity
form so we can look at the capitalist
mode of production in this purest way
but in practice we live in mixed modes
of production there is still slavery in
our society there is still serfdom and
indentured kinds of personal
relationships of domination between
people and we have this overbearingly
burgeoning thing we call the capitalist
mode as well it's always mixed but if
you want to do it analysis of capital
you got to start by abstracting from all
that messiness and try to come up with
some some pure Concepts not formal but
form has a kind of a different meaning
here but you got to start with the
commodity forum and and and get your
pure Theory out of the way and then and
then you can start to look at the real
conditions and and notice the the mixing
and the mat and I think over
determination is a way of of trying to
account for that you know you do instead
of just having a base and a
superstructure you have the level of the
economic base the means of production
and the the relations of production that
obtain as a result of that configuration
and then the ideological superstructure
he's breaking it down into different
levels
all right you have the level of the
economics still but you also have the
political the societal and the
theoretical sometimes he calls it
theological
sometimes he even just puts philosophy
up there on the fourth level
and you got to look at those four levels
so I I thought it was a little bit like
systems theory in that way because it's
very much like Talcott Parsons for yeah
kinds of ways of of analyzing through
his social theory but at that time in
the 60s you know American social theory
was seen as Bourgeois science so they
had no truck with it but
alphaspheres Theory does have some like
strange Echoes of it so he's opening it
up right that's what that's what and
that's essentially what you know
Chantal moof and or I mean yeah and then
Ernesto leclaw were saying is that like
if you want to save the the base
superstructure distinction then then
like Alpha Sarah represents the most
advanced kind of fanciest footwork way
of of preserving this basic base
superstructure distinction and for them
they just like they just say like let's
just get rid of that like you know they
they don't see these levels these four
levels as as sort of
relatively autonomous levels in which
the economic level is in the last
instance the determining level but the
the last instance may just like never
come because things keep happening other
things keep happening they just say
the last instance not the last
instance we don't want any of that we
just want to have relatively autonomous
spheres that are equally determinative
of History
we I I honestly I went through a bit of
a struggle with this because
part of what it is to say that every
event is over determined
it's the same as saying that every event
is unknowable you can't know causation
causation is not the sort of thing that
you can figure out
which I agree with so I'm that's not the
part I was struggling with
but I I feel the pain of those marxists
who are like well then there's no
practice
because if what you're saying is true
then it's impossible and I feel like
he's right you can't reduce and this is
a systems theory term you can't reduce
infinite complexity
to the sort of puzzle that you can just
figure out and then walk away from it
because you finished it what this is to
say epistemologically
and he uses marks to defend this that
history is infinitely complex
and for him this is to be found in Marx
the infinite complexity is in the fact
that the the relationship over the means
of production is never the same it's
never the same in one situation to the
next in the same Society let alone in
history as a whole
so
yeah I would say many groups right
there's there's there's many
underclasses you could call them right
like there's not just the working class
in the industrial Factory there's many
different kinds yeah there's the
prisoners in the prison system that are
also producing they're not part of the
working class especially in the private
prisons in the states right yeah so he's
saying once you get down to or once you
try to get down to the Bare Bones of
this
you're going to be doing simplification
and this is true I have to assert this
is true of any theory always Theory you
need to simplify but the starting
position is really what he's object
objecting to because
in a Marxist Paradigm and I guess he
would call this Orthodox Marxism
or we you sometimes use that as a
shorthand but it applies to so many
people who are like I'm a Marxist and
then I'm going to do it this way which
is to generalize history and then find
the details that fit your generalization
and on the contrary this concept of over
determination is to say
there's this inertia in things that
happen there's an inertia that is caused
by
complexity that cannot ultimately be
reduced there is always a gap
in this distinction between I am now
talking about the political sphere I am
now talking about the social sphere I am
now talking about the sphere of Labor
whatever the that means so in a
sense I can see why people would
disagree with this even though he's
right because it takes away the
theorist's job a little bit or it says
your job doesn't matter nearly as much
as you think it does because you're
basically standing back from a history
that you're a part of
um inexorably and you're writing a story
about it and you want us to take the
story seriously
and I don't know that's why
I I I understand why people would object
to it because sometimes really what we
need is a good story well you need to
get the workers to rise up is not a
bunch of
theoretical complexity you need a good
story but on the other hand this is true
because
it's beholden to the omnipotence of
thought the omnipotence of human reason
to say I can figure out what caused what
in any context you know so this is why
he likes the scientific Marxism as
opposed to the humanist Marxism that
just ushers in sneakily through the back
door a whole bunch of humanist and
Enlightenment ideals
yeah or or it's a quote uh the
comfortable and reassuring idea of a
pure simple dialectical schema which in
its very Simplicity seems to have
retained a memory of the hegelian model
and its faith in resolving power of the
abstract contradiction as such abstract
contradiction we gotta look at the real
contradictions which which even a
transformed kind of like hegelian
dialectic taken out of its speculative
philosophy mystical shell would not give
us because Marx does not take all of
hegel's
components of his dialectic he takes
some of them like you know you can see
quantity and quality you can see those
things in in capital and he makes
hegelian moves any and he even you can
quote mark saying like I I flirt with
hegelian formulations as a way of kind
of cocketting with my work but I don't
know to the degree which he's committed
to the
dialectic as a methodology or is is is
in question here but I mean that that's
true that what you're saying that
complexity of the labor situation right
like I could not help
and by the way a good shorthand for
remembering over determination is just
read that section on Russia and he says
Russia you know the situation in Russia
was precisely a result of the intense
over determination of the basic class
contradiction
I couldn't help but think of the United
States as being the place today is that
not what we would then need to look for
is where in the world right now is
accruing
this level of intense over determination
where you have like sort of backwards
and forwards elements so close together
it's like the United States
right like Banning abortion right now
and look at the the working class
struggles going on right now in the news
recently I have seen uh strikes coming
from rail workers from all those crazy
white noise Style Don de Lilo
crashes releasing chemicals I've been
seeing
nurses and and medical workers the
Starbucks stuff yeah all that
unionization stuff at Starbucks and
Amazon I've been seeing all kinds of
different groups the Uber drivers like
EV like so many different like how do we
bring all of that together that what
needs to happen is is what he calls here
now a fusion if this situation is Right
which it seems to be in the United
States but who knows then there
must be some kind of like the now here's
the situation for a fusion to emerge but
you're never going to see this if you're
using the dialectic untransformed you're
just gonna see you know Simple Pure
contradictory ideas in an abstract
progression of History towards some kind
of end
which is whereas anti-humanism comes
from there's no subject of History he's
saying that's one of his famous lines
right there's no subject of History
we're not you know that's what
anti-humanism or the problem of the
subject of History we're looking it's
like what I said last time we're looking
for the Revolutionary subject where is
it where is it where is it by the 60s
it's like okay well it's not the working
class because they they like their abuse
they want to be whipped so who is it is
it is it is it someone is it new
sexualities is it new I don't know job
groups that are emerging is it it's us
it's the students is it is it me I don't
know no like you gotta look who's the
revolution no the revolution has to
produce the subjects that's the whole
point you never know until it happens
and it might not ever happen yeah that I
wanna I wanna stress that that's a great
Insight man I really
I'm sitting here stroking my beard
thinking about that because
the Revolutionary subject
I don't know if you wanna if you want to
go back to the the French Revolution and
say this is like the bonded bourgeoisie
and then all the hungry people behind
them and then in a in a Marxist
formulation or at least a crudely
Marxist formulation the kind of Marxism
that we're trying to deny here
representationalism then the subject of
History
is not individuals any longer it's the
proletariat it's the the proletarian
class
suddenly comes into awareness hopefully
we pray and hope and sit on our hands
waiting and then that becomes the
Revolutionary subject of History mm-hmm
but this is saying the idea the
anti-humanism aspect of it is
subjectivity does not precede events
events
produce subjectivities and if you know
altuzer's ideological State apparatuses
his theoretical example is the
interaction with the police is what
creates your subjectivity in certain
cases so or Lacon even your interaction
with the mirror is what casts you into
the imaginary and you become the eye
that says I after that and you know what
you're talking about but you actually
don't know what you're talking about so
this the confrontation is what creates
what we call subjects after the fact but
the wrong-headed version of this
philosophy is to say that subjects come
first that if we only awoke in all of
them if we turned off Fox News and force
them to read The Communist Manifesto
then the revolution would occur but the
case is you no one no one has the
freedom the Consciousness the control to
make that happen the end we could call
it the environment to to use our systems
theory again the environment causes
subjectivities so the only thing that
could do a revolution
is not the status quo at the moment it
doesn't look like I'd say we're not sure
but crises for example
widespread crises produce
subjectivities but you can't produce the
subjectivity first
yeah to bring about the crisis to bring
about the revolution true yeah so so
that's a better formulation than I did
it's like yeah yeah we have no
subject of history and he also wants to
get rid of the historicism of of Marx's
thinking which which sounds a little bit
strange at first
but historicism
would be maybe associated with someone
like uh Foucault now
um but just
I think historicism
instead of historical the dialectic is
historical but it's not historic cyst
and when you say historic cyst what
you're talking about is is is sort of a
relativistic position then this relative
like the ideas and the possibilities of
that time are relative to that point in
time
you're historicizing your historic cyst
like it's like I I want to read
Shakespeare as a historicist okay I got
to go back and look at like Productions
in the 17th century and and and and try
to see
like what the meaning of the play is
based on like what people believe during
that time what does Shakespeare then
mean in The Next Century I gotta go look
at that there's no kind of enduring
continuity between those sorts of things
and
and for the dialectic right there is
continuity the the pattern is continuity
and Interruption right it's the back and
forth It's the pendulum we always we
kind of have that phrase right like one
step forward two steps back that implies
there's continuity and Interruption for
for altazar that's historicist
historical would mean that there are
just breaks there are not you know
history has breaks and then there's the
old is that have gone and there's
something new and there's a break
there's a kind of discontinuity to
history but there's still so we don't we
can't historicize because like well
we're in the new how do we really ever
get back to what people would have
thought at that time we can only kind of
look from our position in history and
see the meaning in relation to ourselves
that's all that's all we can do it's
you're not being a historicist you're
you're just historical
yeah historicism is kind of just like
saying everything has a Direction
and you can you can't tell what the
direction is at the moment even
according to historicists but you can
tell after the fact
oh we became more free by positing this
and this or this event happened and it
produced
more freedom than had it existed before
the French Revolution say or now from
our position we can see how this was all
culminating to this end point kind of
way of thinking the wig interpretation
of history is that all of history led to
us in our democracy
um but yeah history is not that kind of
object history is not that kind of thing
that can be studied as it has a
direction to believe in that is to
believe in this
omnipotence of thought this Kingdom of
thought that is in the ultimate sense
the most true thing that the real is
rational and the rational is real
Hegel get rid of that says altuzer get
out of that thinking
this is an infinitely complex
chain chain Network I don't know what
you'd call it they're in so many
independent variables so many dependent
variables that
producing a single narrative from our
minuscule perspective and I'm
editorializing a little bit because this
is my view it's not in the text but to
to generalize your experience to the
whole of History it's just stupid and
it's its own contradiction
but language makes that possible back to
the structuralists language makes that
possible
yeah like his his idea of the unevenness
of of capitalist development I think
speaks to that as well yeah it's not
like a chain as so much as thinking of
it as as like fragments heterogeneous
fragments historically heterogeneous
fragments even because at one time
remember those four levels I I mentioned
the the the relations of production
level political social theoretical each
of those levels can have components
which may be from different historical
times different periods you could
isolate them you're not homogenizing the
historical period you actually
sort of that's what the historicist
would do is they would look at
everything as you know this homogeneous
sort of bequest
in in some historical periods whereas
Althea sees again just like the Russia
example all of the these
these um contradictions that are
accruing each have their own history
and they each have their own
point of origin and they may be very
different and they may originate even as
as anti-revolutionary Concepts they may
originate as something that was meant to
suppress the working class but the the
fact that they've all come together in
this configuration and this state of
intense over determination means that
something happens there's like a spark
there they're originally
anti-revolutionary because you know you
can't foresee how these things will play
out they're anti-revolutionary thrust
originally when they arrive in this
situation it creates a condition it
creates a conjuncture in which
Revolution becomes possible as in again
this Russia example so even these these
different levels they're not homogeneous
historically they they have all these
different components that each have
their own and so he's opening up this
field as well and within the
superstructural analysis
so that's another
component I think of his historical View
is that they can come from different
modes and different periods of History
you can have again elements of feudalism
and slave economies coexisting with
capitalist modes and and other things as
well it's like it's not unlike um
not unlike but you can probably see the
difference between
Raymond Williams theory of residual
dominant and emergent right you have the
residue of the old mode you have the the
the emergent
let's say
whatever
I don't know something new if we're in
the capitalism would have been emergent
in the period where feudalism was
dominant and then the residual would
have been slave Society or something
before that but you can still see that's
kind of a dialectical chain
as opposed to just these like sort of
fragments of history coexisting in in a
single place in a single time hmm
and yeah and famously too you know
Raymond Williams has his base
superstructure Theory and he tries to
open it up by positing a dialectic
between them right like like the the
bass determines the superstructure and
the superstructure determines the base
there's a there's a mutually
determinative kind of relationship which
I don't know Mutual anything that's
Mutual to me seems like a seems like a
trap yeah I'm trying to theoretically
anyway I'm puzzled but I'm trying to fit
this into where you're talking about all
these all these modes exist together
like for example we still have a queen
oh no we don't we still have a king
you and I are are subjects of the crown
and ultimately like the Marxist view I
don't know if this is Marx or just
marxists
because it sounds like marks to me but I
think altazira would point out that
there's more contradictions than one in
play here that they did not gain wealth
by the exploitation of Labor necessarily
they have they have accumulated wealth
from a previous system and the
accumulation still exists except that
they don't own it the crown lands are
now owned by the government and the
government is able to rent them or you
know lease them to private companies so
is that the same type of contradiction
as exists between the bourgeoisie and
the proletariat or is that a different
form of contradiction I'm sure there's
actually probably an easy answer to this
that I just don't know but at least I
can say
this is not the same thing as
bourgeoisie and proletariat as the
subject of exploitation
um
yeah I would even think back to um again
to the when we were doing the
situationists and I read that article
about
um like the the was it the riots
and um the board was almost saying like
here's the Revolutionary subject it is
it is uh it is black people in the
United States there's the Revolutionary
subject that's kind of he almost
explicitly says that whereas I think
Alpha Sarah would see
you know again
these coexisting different ways of being
like in Canada I would look at like
indigenous ways of being in their modes
of production right that have this this
they have a relationship with capitalism
in Canada and all their Crown Land and
stuff is relevant there too what you're
saying but but it's different it's it's
a different mode of production it's it's
something that's managed to survive the
immense that was cologne that
still is colonialism
and so you have these mixed mixed modes
you have different things I don't know
maybe I'm getting it wrong but that
seems to be what he might be thinking
about well I do want to clarify these
are these are taken into the new mode
right but if I think what he was he
would say if you're going to look at a
specific mode of production you can't
account
for colonialism specifically Within
a bourgeoisie or a bourgeoisie versus
proletariat system
because then he would be you would be
leaving too much out but I wanted to at
least close on this or or ask the
question because this is one of the most
interesting questions to come out of
this Marxism is very often Accused by
people who don't understand it and
sometimes by people who do understand it
as being economically determinist
and altuzar tries to
carefully
step around this
allow it to be possible but not really
say that this is the case
so
if you're an economic determinist then
you say in the end all history all
historical change even most historical
events in the end in the last place you
can say
has some economic cause and angles
specifically says if you're saying
that's the only cause you're wrong I'm
not with you that's an abstraction that
doesn't make sense but
if you if you were to carry the critique
far enough at the end you'd find an
economic cause that you could
specifically Define
and what does altuzira say about that
you yeah in the end it is economic but
we never reached the end because we're
always within the process so I wanted to
know how you interpreted that part
yeah like I think in the last instance
is like a uh
it's like almost like a long durray
thing right it's a if you look at Broad
swaths of History then economic forces
are determinative but when you look at
the local and really get into the fine
grain stuff that's that's not going to
help you and it's just the last instance
let's cast it out of our analysis for
now and and keep it in the background
that's kind of what I thought about it
but then you know this last instance
never comes thing right like
later thinkers will hold that up as one
of the contortions of of Alpha Syrian
Theory like like look at this look at
this pretzel he's had to twist himself
into he's had to say it's the last
instance with the last insist ever comes
so that's that's a problem for some
people and and the cloud move want to
just jettison the whole distinction
you know
and Alpha Sarah wants to break it up
into four pieces
and others have different solutions to
that problem okay
um
but I I don't know I I still today have
the sense that that
capital
is what runs the show no matter what
you know there's there's local movements
that can perhaps evade or or or insulate
themselves from markets and from global
capitalism
but in the end it's destined to fail
right
like
the fall of the Soviet Union the entry
of of China into the capitalist World
Markets like these things it just seems
like you know it's the capital right now
just seems like the water that can just
cut any mountain down given enough time
that's that's what I kind of think I
still think this last instance
it's never fully realized but it's
always kind of there I don't know you
get the sense when you're looking at
politics when you're looking at
decisions your school is making when you
look at even your own life what I'm
what's what's going to motivate my
behavior today it's often money
so I don't I don't see why this last
instance thing is such a big deal but I
do see the point of you know getting
into these obstructs theoretical
discussions or the at least the impulse
to do it to see exactly like where to
draw that line like where does this
instance come into play What's the
freedom between you know the structure
structural causation and you know free
choice of of an agent within this
situation I don't know it's difficult to
say but I think we do have a kind of
local freedom but I don't know money
makes the glass call in in most
situations that I'm
privy to yeah I think he uh I mean I I
can see what he's doing there because
the intention is to say like I'm not
throwing this whole thing in the trash
can
he's saying I think you know money is
the most important thing but if you go
into a theoretical situation where
you're looking for an explanation and
you start out with money in the first
instance and say like if I follow the
money then I've explained it then you're
gonna get a lot of things wrong like if
you come to for example the history of
Art and say every artist did everything
they did for economic reasons in the end
you would be wrong
in the end did the discourse of art just
become wholly subservient to Capital yes
um but the whole point I think of this
of this last instance thing is
you never you're never at the conclusion
because history is still history it's
still a process of infinity events
Infinity individual decisions and if you
start out by saying every single
decision that's ever been made has been
made with uh Financial incentive
or to preserve the system of capital
then you just you're You're Gonna Miss
the trees because you're only looking
for a forest
yeah it does make me appreciate the
postmodern move to to level these these
sort of conceptual hierarchies
because if if economics is is
determinative then it's at the top of
the conceptual hierarchy and Marxist
thinking
and to me that's kind of like trading a
well like a Cartesian like ontological
dualism for a methodological dualism
where your method is divided down the
middle between looking at infrastructure
and on the other hand you're looking at
culture or superstructure or whatever
you want whatever the
superstructure really is
and so you just you just trade one
dualism for another
and so I think collapsing these
distinctions are D hierarchizing them or
are flattening that out it's not a flat
ontology because it's not ontological
it's methodological but even that's a
problem right the difference between the
system and the method that's still a
problem because the method is all
important so how do we
see infrastructure and superstructure as
sort of collapsed into one another
I think that would be maybe the
postmodern move is to see them as as
often switching places yeah one one
person's infrastructure is another
person's object of contemplation there's
no why would why would we point to one
thing and say that is part of the
infrastructure like you can't really do
that because you're abstracting already
from the messiness of life and and so
you you're just fetishizing your method
methodological fetishism yeah you can
instead of you can see that with uh
beaudryard for example like the signs
this exchange of signs is even more
important than the exchange of
Commodities yeah so hopefully if anybody
has any recommendations on on new things
new thinking on these subjects but I
would look at sort of the newer marxists
too like um
uh Yale I gotta hand it to Yale
University they they've had their open
Yale free lectures they post a lot of
great stuff on on YouTube Just free
lectures I saw one between uh I forget
the other guy's name the guy I'm always
harping on about Mike Michael Heinrich
Mikhail Heinrich who has a kind of
alcazarian and new Marxist influence
neuya Marx uh who he's really against
certain ways of looking at Marx and
their others they're I mean they're they
were arguing about chapter one of
capital and how different their
readings were was insane like is value
determined in the productive process or
does the market have to play a role like
is is it is value determined by
production and exchange is the question
and for some Marxist it's production and
exchange is sort of dependent on that
value creation whereas for others no
value is created in the market and
within you know the capitalist looks at
that and then like can then look at
their workshop and be like okay this is
how I have to organize things
so and I'm a little more convinced by
the sort of
maybe the Heinrich
not neo-alphus area but like he's
definitely like sympathetic towards this
developmental reading of Marx where
there were revisions maybe not breaks
but but evolution in Marx's thinking up
to the end of his life and even Beyond
because we're still like getting new
texts and new drafts of the of capital
and we're still waiting for the Maga
project to publish that enormous
critical edition of all this works it
sounded like you said Mega project
Mark's translation make make alpha sir
great again
ultimately saying here and I think he he
actually goes in on angles for having a
really bad interpretation of what it's
economic in the last instance means but
he is pushing away as a good Levy
straussian might
not astrazian
Levy straussian might in saying that
there's so many objects of concern
that if you reduce economic necessity to
the only necessity in history
which by the way again angles said was
not true so any Marxist who you hear say
saying that that's true disagrees even
with angles who Alpha's I think is wrong
for different reasons but if you look at
if you say everything is only economic
then there's no point in doing anything
in life at all except for economics and
that I'm sorry quite simply is not what
human life is and and now a commercial
for an investment app
now that's not what we want to be doing
here
yeah he I mean economism yeah and
technologism those are the the names for
those kinds of thinking right economism
Market determines everything
Technologies and production determines
everything
so I do think this view where value
which you know
commodity form is constituted by value
and value is an abstraction right it's
abstract labor it abstracts concrete
labor homogenizes it sticks it in value
that becomes part of the commodity form
which is
in exchange values created in this way
and so there's there's a there's a
relationship between production and the
market in the creation of value there's
there's a role for both of those things
so it's kind of a
techno economism I don't know maybe
maybe that's a better maybe that's a
compromise to move forward with instead
of choosing one or the other yeah just
not humanism yeah just not humanism we
can do technology we can do uh economics
but no humanism and what like yeah I
guess what I would say just to conclude
this despite what I say in other media
and despite what I say because it's
reduced to sound bites and 270
characters
there is no such thing as singular
causation that's a thing that I will
hold to that's what altuzer is saying
here so it's useful
heuristically it's useful because
sometimes you just have to tell a story
but if you look at the complexity of the
world of all the decisions that cannot
ever be added up into an aggregate of
decisions there's always accidents
there's nothing necessary then you got
to be more careful which is funnily
enough the same thing that many of the
post-structuralist language people say
about language there is no
singular references that you can just
close and leave on the table and walk
away from yeah and over determination is
a nice way of of saying that complex
causation
you know we might talk about systems
theory we might talk more about circular
causation the way that
but even in that case you gotta be kind
of careful but yeah complexity right
causal complexity is always what is
going on there's no simple abstract
principles that are simply opposed and
then absorbed and suppressed which is
exactly we studied this for two months
this is exactly what Gita bore just had
no understanding of the spectacle that's
all fake production and ownership that's
all real all we're dealing with is fake
they don't interact at all
that's wrong sorry
yeah yeah because that's you know yeah
beauchery art is is probably a little
more nuanced and uh and deep than than
and and then he would never say that
there's like sort of an economic behind
the the spectacle which is what it's all
really about the spectacle is just the
veneer on on Capital circulation or de
Liz right there's not there's not these
layers there's not like the one layer
that leads into the next one or the one
layer that is primary and then secondary
layers on top of that you need imminent
Theory not layered of
the the important things that we've
decided are important compared to the
accidents that we've decided are not
important yeah yeah he flirted early on
with the surface depth stuff and then by
the time he's writing with gotori
they're talking about
double articulation which is
quite different a whole other can of
worms but yeah I I like this move
towards I don't know I guess you'd say
away from maybe hegelian objective
idealism which is which is like monistic
right it's Mo it's not a dualism it's
it's it seems to me to be monistic uh
but it's
idealist in its objectivity and we need
to be more
of a materialist objectivist and and and
and even like pay attention to when like
methodological dualism begins to creep
into our thinking and we start to make
these separations and forget that
they're just formal yeah that they're
just to help us understand yeah it's a
it's a monism with very knowable moments
as opposed to this which is an
anti-dualism
that's just saying there's no in the in
the end case there's no one who knows
anything which is not to say that all
knowledge is equivalent it's just to say
that whenever you know one thing you are
simplifying it at the expense of another
thing and that's just the way that
knowledge works yeah so his his I think
all of it adds up to
um
I I like this term from Carrie Wolfe
even though he's criticizing it uh he
calls it a syncretic totality
so you gotta you gotta look at the
totality
and see it as a Confluence of of of
different fragments from different
historical periods and not as a
homogeneous whole but as a heterogeneous
totality
which includes sort of past and future
in it old modes new modes emergent modes
fading out of existence modes kind of
things happening all at the same time
and keep an eye on the United States for
that uh intense collection of of over
determination yeah that's the thing that
there is a totality but it's not a
determined totality it's a totality that
is not just too complex because there's
too much information it is just
fundamentally too complex to ever become
the object of knowledge which is why you
can't predict but you're right
yeah it's contested and conflicted all
the way down there's no it's it's like a
battlefield right you look at it you
look at a text like a war zone and even
even if it was written by one person you
go into it and you try to see like where
are these ideas coming from how is this
like a battlefield that could be
contradicting itself and those
contradictions will be revealing if
you're doing a symptomatic reading of
things uh-oh we're getting into derida
before we get into derida let's not
let's
specters almost an hour and a half so we
will close it and ship it Eric thank you
very much for being with me I think that
was uh productive let's call it
productive
yeah my pleasure bag him and tag them
all right
thank you listeners uh I always like
your feedback but we are gonna close it
there thank you listeners special thanks
to patrons of course
over and out
peace
foreign
[Music]